MALE SPEAKER: So
welcome, everyone.
I'm very excited that we have
Steve Sisgold here today.
His new book, "Whoe
Body Intelligence:
Get Out of Your Head and Into
Your Body to Achieve Greater
Wisdom, Confidence,
and Success."
I actually wanted to read one
of the reviews of the book.
It's actually from our
very own Rachel Romero,
who set this talk up as one
of our [? G+ ?] volunteers.
What Rachel says is,
"This is the intelligence
everyone needs.
'Whole Body
Intelligence' will help
you navigate life more easily.
It helps me understand
unconscious messages
my body cues tell me, and
transforms negative beliefs I
carry into positive ones,
all by using the intelligence
of my own body."
Rachel Romero, Sales
Manager at Google.
I'm really looking
forward to this talk,
and I'd like to turn this
over to Steve Sisgold.
STEVE SISGOLD: Thank you.
I've been to Google three--
it's my third time here.
I love the energy and
coming to the campuses.
And just, of course,
I'm using it every day.
Obviously, I get
my Google Alerts.
And I'm Googling.
And I used Google
Maps to get down here.
So, it's pretty
exciting to be here.
Today is going to be fun.
It's going to be interactive.
For those of you out there,
it'll be interactive as well.
And we're not going
to just listen.
But I'm going to
do some assessment.
We're going to take
notice of different things
we feel in our body,
how that relates
to beliefs, how that
relates to our energy, how
that relates to our stress.
And just to become aware
of what we're feeling.
You know, for me,
people always say to me,
how did you get into writing
a book about whole body
intelligence?
And I'm not a doctor.
And I was not a
psychologist, even
though I did go to school,
and after my business career,
and got into body
centered psychotherapy.
But basically, I was
in sales and business.
I had a purpose.
I felt good.
I was working with people
that I believed in.
And I really helped people.
But I noticed a few things.
This sounds strange, but I
would write and put together
these campaigns for people.
And then I noticed that
they would say one thing,
and their body would
say something else.
They'd be talking about how
their program relaxes people,
but they'd be shaking their leg.
Or how they're really
into opening their heart,
and they'd be clinging
in front of themselves.
So I'm, "Wow,
something's off here."
And I really became
interested in learning
how our body's intelligence,
and our connection to our body
would actually work
towards success,
optimization of our
productivity, our energy,
finding our purpose.
And one of my niches,
which we'll work on today,
is finding beliefs
that live in the body,
because the body's been
there since day one, right?
Everything we ever felt, did,
there's been enough science.
Candace Pert and
other scientists
who have shown that memories
actually live in the body.
Things happened.
Most of us, when things happen
that were uncomfortable,
we did two things, usually.
We held our breath,
just not to feel,
just that initial response,
the sympathetic nervous system,
to go into that.
And then secondly, we
would roll our body
to hold onto things
that we didn't
get to speak or get
to resolve over,
didn't get to express out.
So I just found pretty
much working in business,
working with people, I
would just ask them like,
"Tell me-- tell me something.
Tell me how you would like
to see your department go."
And I would hear
stuff like, "Well, I'd
really like to have the
most-- [COUGH] excuse me."
I go, OK.
Try it again.
I'd really like to have
the most succ-- [COUGH]
--having trouble with
that word success.
And then I just started
asking questions like, "Well I
notice when you say you want to
have a successful department,
or you want your group to
be the most successful,
there's a little something
going on in your body.
You see even though the mind
is like, Yeah, I can do it.
And I want it.
And I believe in it.
The body still has the memories.
And sometimes it will
kind of blindside us
and get in the way of us
actually having what we want.
Either we're
communicating something,
or it's just an old belief.
I'll give you my own
examples in a minute.
But this one fellow,
basically when
he started choking on the
word success over and over,
I basically had him
go into his body.
You know Einstein said,
You can't solve a problem
with the same thinking
that created it.
And a lot of us try to
keep thinking through it.
So I just started really
asking people like, Well,
what do you notice here?
I call it the body
first approach.
Basically, a loop back to my
body to inquire instead of just
with the mind, what could
I learn from my body?
And things would happen
like, he'd say, Well.
I'd say, Say it out
loud a few times.
And then listen to the response.
Listen to the
impact in your body.
And with this
particular executive,
he found that when he said
the word success something got
triggered.
And of course, like most
of us, what do we do?
We don't want to
feel uncomfortable,
so we push it down.
We ignore it.
We numb it.
We do everything we can
to get away from it.
My work was to get people
to actually go into it.
So as he went into it,
the body starts to respond
and the familiar
feelings come back.
And as he got
smaller, he had kind
of what's called a somatic
recall, or a cellular memory,
if you've ever
heard those terms.
And basically by feeling in his
body and not running from it,
but actually breathing
and going into it,
he remembered something
that he had pushed aside
for many years.
When he was young, his--
during Christmas and holidays,
he would look out and
see everybody got wagons,
and bikes, and new toys.
And he didn't get anything.
And every time he would
say to his dad, Hey,
dad what happened?
Why didn't I get something?
His dad would say, well son,
just don't worry about it.
You know money, success
will make you sick.
So you don't need it.
Well, a little kid hears that.
He takes it in maybe
one or 1,000 times.
Forgets about it,
but where did it go?
Where did that
unexpressed feeling go?
It lives in the body.
And you'll see
some of that today.
So basically he had a belief
that he carried in his body.
And then you could
see it in his--
what I call his billboard.
Somehow we're saying to
people, if I'm too successful,
I'll get sick.
So we worked on expressing
and getting that out,
get those feelings and
that energy moving.
And then we work on
what I call vital belief
versus the viral
belief, bringing
in a belief that actually
was, I could be successful.
And I could be vibrant.
I could be healthy.
And of course, his body
rejected it at first.
But eventually, he embodied it.
His whole presentation
to the world shifted.
So we're going to do
some of that today too.
So just to start here on
the body first approach.
We're going to bring our
whole self into the room
and into our life and our work.
And I just want to,
even as you're eating
or whatever you're doing
right now, just take a moment,
with no judgment,
just pure observation.
And just notice where your
breath is originating from.
Just notice, with no
judgment analysis.
Like, is it way down
in your lower belly?
Or is it coming up in the chest?
We're going to learn
some things just
about ourselves in the moment.
So take a moment
and just notice.
Obviously, if we're
breathing down in our belly,
we're in the parasympathetic
nervous system, which
is the place that relaxes.
The digestive system works well.
Your muscles relax.
Your creativity, your
brain is relaxed.
You have more
creativity, more energy.
Unfortunately, a lot
of us breathe up here,
which is that sympathetic
nervous system.
And you know, biologically,
it's there to protect us.
So what it does is it shuts
down the digestive system.
It tenses the muscles.
The heart beats fast, so
we can get up the tree.
You know, I have a dog
that's a good example.
So for instance, he's in
the parasympathetic most
of the time.
He's just hanging out.
He's just eating his bone.
As soon as the UPS
truck pulls up,
which happens a lot nowadays.
The UPS truck, he hears
it, and he goes right
into his sympathetic.
Man, he's like,
there's no digestion.
There's no room for food.
There's no time to
breathe or relax.
It's like he's got
to get to the door.
And he's at the door.
And he's waiting.
And the UPS just rings the bell.
And then as soon as that break
is released from the truck,
and the UPS pulls away, he
goes right back to his bone
like it never happened.
We don't do that, unfortunately.
A lot of us have
that sympathetic,
and we get caught in it.
And unfortunately
we're in it too often,
sometimes frozen in it.
And we're feeling
that stress like we
need to get up that tree
if a tiger's chasing us.
But it's not actually
working for us,
because it tires us out.
And it causes digestive
problems, and heart,
and blood pressure.
So the second thing to
notice is, is it easier
for you to breathe in?
Just notice.
That's receiving, by
the way, oxygen, energy,
lifeforce, breathing in.
Or is it easier to
breathe out, expressing?
I have found that about
95, 98% of the talks I do,
people find that breathing
in relates to receiving.
How much can I take in?
Compliments, success,
abundance, love.
And how much, my outbreath,
how free am I to express?
So anybody that would
just like to call out,
did you notice anything that you
didn't know just a minute ago
about your breathing?
Anybody?
Just call it out.
Breathing in from your
stomach or your chest.
Did you notice anything?
Just take a moment
and tune into that.
And then you could scan your
whole body and just notice,
is there something I wasn't
aware of a moment ago?
Was I crunching up?
Was my fist tight?
Was I not breathing?
Are my shoulders up to my ears?
Am I thinking about
the future or the past,
instead of being in this moment?
And just scan your body and
again just ask yourself,
is there anything I just
noticed that I wasn't
aware of five minutes ago?
Because most of the time,
we're not in our body, right.
We're in our screens.
In fact, constantly
changing habits,
like, for instance,
the smartphones,
I got the smartphone the
first weekend it came out.
And this is what started
to happen, right?
The looking down like this.
Not realizing through the years
that it was pulling my muscles
up in my neck.
So the new habit I'm learning is
to look at my phone like this.
But it's more
comfortable to do this.
It's more familiar.
But there's a huge difference
in how it affects my energy,
cuts off your oxygen,
makes you tight,
contracted, versus expanded.
So just take a moment if anybody
wants to call out anything.
It's interactive.
Anything you noticed that you
didn't know five minutes ago,
about your breathing, your
posture, your scanning
your body, something
you were maybe gripping.
Does anybody want
to call it out.
You're welcome to, please.
AUDIENCE: I've
always wondered why
I have more difficulty breathing
in for longer periods of time
than breathing out.
And if I relate it to
what you just said,
I am a very expressive person.
I'm talkative.
I'm outgoing.
I'm extroverted.
And taking in what
you just said,
now I want to look at, OK, how
am I blocking, receiving then
through my breathing.
STEVE SISGOLD: I
think that's excellent
because you know the truth
is when things happen,
for instance, 70% of the people
who have won the lottery have
lost it back.
And you think, how
could they do that?
If I had $20 billion, I
would never blow it, right?
And yet what happens
is it's familiar.
It's familiar to be broke.
It's familiar to be having
trouble with your bills.
All of a sudden there's millions
of dollars and it's like,
can't take it.
And that happens
sometimes with love.
We want to meet
that perfect person.
But old wiring, old beliefs,
old feelings in the body
will get us to not
be comfortable,
and we won't really be
expressing who we are.
So I just found that breathing
in fully from the belly,
it's going to relax
your nervous system.
It's going to get
you into a place
where you're really
receiving oxygen.
And we need oxygen. We
need that life force.
OK.
Anybody else who wants to
share, just call it out.
That's where we are.
We're just in an open forum,
where you can call out and say,
Hey, I didn't notice
I was crunching up.
I was thinking about
something in the--
that happened this morning.
And I didn't realize
my body was holding it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for giving
the talk today.
STEVE SISGOLD: Yeah,
thank you for being here.
AUDIENCE: I personally noticed
that my posture definitely
affects my breathing
the most, whether it's
my shoulders in versus
my shoulders out.
And even when I'm standing
at my desk versus sitting,
I find that my breathing
is much healthier, lower
rather than higher in my chest.
STEVE SISGOLD: Thank you.
Yeah, thank you.
What did you notice today, just
in the short little exercise?
AUDIENCE: Well, even
when I-- excuse me--
even when I was
sitting down just now,
whether I had my leg on
my other, crossed, right?
I could notice my
breathing kind of like cave
in versus my shoulders back.
It was really interesting.
STEVE SISGOLD: Because
in every moment
there's an expansion
and a contraction.
And if they're not
balanced, then we're
more in the contraction.
When we're contracted,
obviously it's
going to cut off
the oxygen. It's
going to cut off the breathing.
And if we have
something on our mind,
and we don't realize
our body's like this.
Now, I had a wonderful
offer for this new book
from the publisher.
They made me a great deal.
And they said, You can
have it out in 2016.
And I was like, All right.
I mean, that's how it usually
goes, a year, year and a half.
They said, however,
however, if you
can get it done in
seven weeks, we'll
put it out in the summer of '15.
Well that was incentive for me.
Of course, seven
weeks to write a book.
But here's what happened, I
would lean into my computer.
And the more I wrote the
more I would go into it.
And I had no idea.
It constricts your creativity.
It's constricting my breathing.
My fiancee would walk by
because she's into yoga.
And she would yell
out, slump asana.
You know what asana
means, it's posture.
Slump asana.
I go, ah, thank you.
And all of a sudden
my brain would relax.
As we go further, you'll
notice movement opens
a new neural net in your brain.
Anytime you feel
stuck, get up and move.
It starts to open up the brain.
It gets the oxygen moving.
Often we're sitting too much.
So what we're really
focusing on today
is having an expanded awareness.
Instead of just IQ and
EQ, we're going to use BQ.
Obviously, you've
heard a lot about EQ.
And that's basically
that I am feeling
and sensitive to your emotions.
And I'm also compassionate
and feeling my own emotions
[AUDIO OUT] express them.
One thing I've noticed
with EQ is sometimes
people don't know
what they feel.
They go, well, I
think I'm angry.
I'm not sure.
Maybe I'm sad.
I'm just not sure.
So that's where,
again, we use the body.
And we start to breathe,
and notice, and feel.
And the body will allow
us to really notice
what we're feeling and
what we're not feeling.
So with this expanded
awareness, as you can see,
there's a lot of advantages.
You detect stress.
You can notice.
I call the body your
thought monitor.
If you're slumping,
if you're contracting,
most likely you're having
a negative thought,
or you're thinking
something about someone.
It's not a happy thought, right?
When we're happy,
we make a touchdown.
You know, we're like
a big open peacock.
And when we're contracted,
we're like a little bird that's
just been through an oil spill.
So it's just something
to catch every day.
It's like either
we're open or closed.
The same thing
with the breathing.
And that can happen because
the thought is thinking
about something that happened
this morning, or a meeting
later, or an incomplete
communication with someone.
And then the thought creates
a feeling into the body.
And as we go further
on in our talk today,
you'll see how it actually
affects the brain and the body.
Every thought is affecting us.
So I use the body as
a thought monitor.
If I'm slumping,
there's a reason.
There's something going
on that's making me slump.
If I'm contracting,
there's a reason.
So your body can really
become a great detector.
And you can catch when
you're assuming and blaming,
instead of being body first.
Body first, I'll give
you a quick example.
So I lived in Hawaii
for about six years.
And one day I was
at Waimea Canyon.
If you know about it in
Kauai, it's beautiful.
It's like the Grand
Canyon of Hawaii.
It's pretty amazing.
And I'm sitting on the rock.
And I'm actually feeling
the warmth of the rock.
And as I'm looking
out at the canyon,
I'm noticing and
breathing, and noticing
how expanded the
view makes me feel,
and how beautiful
the colors are.
And I'm having a
whole body experience.
Up comes a tourist bus and the
guy gets off, and he comes up.
And then right
away he says, hey,
have you ever heard
of little river?
Not sure.
Yeah, little river
is where I live.
And it doesn't look like this.
Yeah, we don't have
this where I live.
And he went, took a picture
and got back on the bus.
So that's somebody that didn't
have a whole body experience,
you see.
He barely-- I don't know
even if he looked at it.
But the point is
we do that a lot.
At work, somebody drops
something on our desk.
Somebody asks us something
that demands of us.
And instead of
feeling and noticing
the impact it had on
us, we go into our mind.
Well, they're wrong.
And I'm going to call my friend.
I'm going to talk about it.
We waste a lot of time.
So imagine if we just
took that moment and went,
Wow, I'm noticing my stomach
got tight when she said that.
I wonder what that might be.
And often as we go further
into presentation today,
you'll see often
that's a memory.
That's something that has
nothing to do with the moment.
But the moment
triggered the past.
And as we learn more about
ourselves, and how we get
triggered, whether
we've been betrayed.
So on our first
date, we're already
projecting that this person
is going to betray us.
I was a sales trainer.
It was part of how I got
into this is watching people.
Here's the truth.
When I leaned forward,
because I was a little needy
and I wanted the sale,
my customers leaned back.
And then I was like, I
didn't get any sales.
When I leaned back and
was aware of my breathing,
my tensions, my tightening,
and I relaxed, I got orders.
I became the number one sales
rep out of 500 salespeople.
And it was an inner
game the whole time.
My machines were the same.
I sold business equipment.
They weren't much different
than anybody else's.
But it was my presentation.
It was basically, the
more I relaxed I was,
the more clients
wanted to be with me.
So just take a moment and think
about that, and feel into this.
And in my journey, I've
been very fortunate
that I've worked in
a medical office.
So I've been working
on this with medical.
People have asthma, tight,
arthritis and stuff.
A lot of it is
unexpressed feelings,
and unexpressed emotions.
So if you're young, I want to
encourage you, breathe, move,
and express.
Everyday, constantly moving.
You'll see why in a few moments.
But not to hold things in.
I think holding
things in is really
where we start to
build up that tension.
It starts to wreck
havoc on our bodies.
So I've worked in
medical offices.
I've been in a lot of
buildings down here
in the Silicon Valley.
I've been very fortunate to
give speeches and so forth.
One day I got a phone call.
And it was a school of
physical therapists.
And they said, how would
you like to come to Mexico?
We're taking a whole group down
to this really remote place.
And we want them to learn
whole body intelligence.
Hey, that sounds great.
So I fly to Mexico.
And I get off.
I'm taken to this nice hotel.
We have a nice lunch.
And then I'm told, the boat
will be here in a few moments.
OK, good.
So the boat comes.
It's a little fisherman's boat.
And I and half the
class get in it.
And we come up to this remote
island that has no electricity.
And I get there.
And we go to this
beautiful palapa.
Like this nice house with these
open windows and everything.
This is where we're
going to have a class.
But you as the teacher, you're
going to have the top palapa.
Oooh, top palapa.
OK.
Top of the mountain.
Meantime, it's a
straight-up jungle.
This is not a picture.
But I want to give you an idea
of that palapa that I got,
that amazing palapa.
It was like this in the
sense that it had no walls.
It wasn't next to a river.
It was in the middle
of the jungle.
But it was like this that
basically I got up there
and there was a
hammock and no walls.
And I'm at the
top of the jungle.
And I'm thinking, Oh my god,
you know, what did I do?
What did I sign up for?
So it's almost sunset.
And it gets dark.
And I'm hearing [ANIMAL NOISES]
all these animals under me.
I'm like, Oh my
god, this is crazy.
Oh, by the way, the guy
who carried my suitcase up
to the palapa told me,
turn over your shoes
because there's a
lot of scorpions.
I'm like, oh, great, great.
So, I'm turning over my shoes.
I'm laying in this hammock,
like, oh my god, what am I--
how am I going to get
through the night?
I just let the animals
below me go to sleep.
I got up in the morning and
it was beautiful, peacocks
and everything.
But here's what I want to share.
I got up and there
was a vibrant village.
I had never seen
anything like it before.
There was no electricity.
There were no phones.
There were no smartphones.
There was nothing,
except they woke up.
And I got up pretty early.
I mean as soon as that
sun, I was like ready
to get out of my
palapa and go down.
Everybody was up.
Everybody was moving.
Everybody was doing something.
Little, older, it didn't
matter, lifting, grabbing,
moving, smiling, happy.
And it was pretty amazing to
see such a vibrant community.
No one was laying down.
No one looked depressed.
Everybody knew exactly what
they were supposed to do.
So I started my class.
And I had people
breathing and releasing
and getting some stress out.
And a couple people were
making some loud sounds.
So all of a sudden, a bunch
of the villagers ran up.
And the one who really
spoke English well
said, what's going on?
What are you doing?
I said two things.
I said, well, we're helping
people release some stress
that they carry in their body.
And they were totally
confused by that.
And I said, and also, maybe
some things from their past
that they want to get rid of.
Well that, they had no idea
what I was talking about.
They said, we don't
understand this concept.
We get the words.
And we understand
what you're saying.
But we don't know
this concept, stress.
Imagine that.
Like this is a village
where people just
get up and live their life.
And then at night, they sing
and it's a whole community
together.
We don't understand
this concept, stress.
Secondly, we don't
know what you mean
by having something in
the past, because they
engage in every moment.
When they're picking something,
they're engaged with it.
When they're playing with the
kids, they're engaged in it.
Unfortunately, a lot
of us, unlike the dog,
we-- something
happens, we freeze.
It goes into our body.
And as you'll see
later, the neural net
starts to stay in that thought.
And then next thing
you know that stress,
even though something happened
a day ago, or a week ago,
or a month ago, or a year
ago, is still in our bodies.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, we carry too much.
So we've got to find
ways to intervene,
catch those thoughts.
And move forward.
So here's what I took
away from the village.
And this is something that each
of us can really learn from.
Number one, they were
all part of a community.
No one was isolated.
No one was alone.
They knew what
their purpose was.
They woke up.
And they just lived.
Secondly, they understood
clearly what their culture was.
They aligned with their culture.
Third, they thrived.
Whatever their role
was, it was fine.
I went around that
village for two weeks.
No one was unhappy.
No, there was no
competition, jealousy.
It was just like, I'm
doing what I'm doing.
And I'm OK with it.
Never felt isolated, they
were engaged in the moment,
no matter what they were doing.
And I watched.
And they were
breathing, and moving,
and expressing, so that their
energy levels were higher.
They weren't exhausted.
They weren't depressed.
They didn't have to run
to coffee at two o'clock.
They were energized and moving.
So they breathed, moved
and expressed themselves.
And they ate a healthy
energizing diet.
So just something to learn.
I came back.
And I was totally committed to--
I started a business exchange.
I got involved in my community.
I changed my diet.
I made sure that I was really
clear about my purpose.
And I was aware of what when I
wasn't engaging in the moment.
When I was stuck in my head,
versus feeling and noticing
in my body.
Years later-- years
later after that,
I heard about this Blue Zones.
I don't know if
you've heard about it.
But there's even a
book out about it now.
And there was some population
experts, some doctors,
some physicists that
went around the world
to look for where people
had higher longevity.
And they found very much
of what I saw that there
was big social engagement.
There was family.
They put less smoking.
They had a clean diet.
But here's the key, constant
moderate physical activity.
Constant.
So when my son was growing
up, because I taught him
how to breathe and move, he
would get up all the time
in his chair.
And the teachers would call me
and go, hey, what's going on.
He's not supposed to stand up.
I went, they're
sitting too long.
So I highly recommend that
you get up from your chairs
as much as you can
and just walk around.
What it'll do is it'll
get you to breathe.
It will get you to move.
But more than anything,
there have been studies done
that show when we move, the
neural nets of our brain
start to open up.
And then we can get
creative thought.
So when I work with a
group, we're walking.
We're moving.
Any time there's a stuck
moment, all right, everybody up.
Let's breathe and move.
And all of a sudden, the
energy in the room changes.
The thoughts change.
And we're out of that
locked in brain neural net.
So movement is a
key to all of this.
Here's, unfortunately,
what a lot of us are doing,
and there's so
much study on this.
I'm sure you've seen it.
You know American Psychiatry
Association-- Psychological
Association, thousands
and thousands of workers,
67% of people aren't engaged.
They're stressed.
80% of people are stressed
at their office visits.
So the point is we obviously
have some stress from change.
A lot of us aren't
used to change.
When we were young [? or ?]
[? something ?] changed.
So resilience really
is the ability
to breathe through, to me, and
move through and tell the truth
when something changes.
So just remember that,
when something changes,
rather than getting into your
mind and getting frozen, get up
and breathe and move and
get that energy moving.
Obviously, the lack
of control at times.
Am I getting enough support?
Stress in relationships,
because we're not
speaking authentically.
We're often just projecting.
Well, when you
did that, when you
did that, versus
the communication
I teach in offices
is when you did that,
or when you said that to me,
I noticed a little stress
in my chest.
It's something that I felt,
or something happened to me.
Sometimes, you can talk
with people like that.
Sometimes you can't.
But the idea is is for
you to be aware of what
I call the body first,
the loop of awareness,
for you to be
aware in your body.
How did that impact me?
When I saw that, how
did that impact me?
When my boss gave me
this, or my project leader
gave me this task,
what happened for me?
So that you can have a
whole body experience
and really be engaged,
what's happening for
me in this moment?
So that's the versus
the blue or the stress.
And of course, as
we know, we used
to be very intrasomatic, right.
This is how we were.
We felt. We smelled.
We sensed.
If you watch babies,
they breathe.
Their belly goes up and down.
They smell.
They're very into
their environment.
Until things happen and then
we go extra extrasomatic.
Basically, extrasomatic
means that we're
trying to get all of our
information from outside.
So what I'm suggesting is
start to go into the body,
because the body was
there from day one.
It will give you information.
If your stomach's yelling,
when you're wanting to say no,
listen to it.
Most of us override it.
I was a people pleaser.
I would override it.
And then I would be so upset.
Why did I say yes to that?
I don't want to do this tonight.
I've made it a habit
to go, wait a second.
You know, I'm getting a no.
Or let me call you back.
So trust your gut.
There's a reason.
Deepak Chopra talks about
the mobile brain in a book
by Candace Pert.
She has an amazing book
around your molecules
and your emotions.
And basically,
what he was saying
is that there's a
mobile brain, meaning
there's brains and
intelligence in our whole body,
except we're all in
smartphones so much
and we're on virtual
that we forget.
So most of us are
living up here.
Secondly, Paul Pearsall wrote
a book, "The Heart's Code."
And what he discovered as a
surgeon, a heart-- transplants,
that the recipients who
actually got the new heart
took on characteristics,
sometimes even food-- the foods
that they desired were
from the person who died.
What does that tell
you about the heart?
Anybody.
AUDIENCE: Muscle memory.
AUDIENCE: Memory.
STEVE SISGOLD: But
imagine that the heart,
not in the body of John,
but in the body of Bill,
Bill starts to take on some
memories, some feeling,
some new thoughts.
There's also a guy
named Larry Gershon.
And Doctor Gershon
talks about the gut.
Says the gut has total neurons.
The gut is like neuropeptides.
The gut is like
the brain up here.
That's why we call
it gut instinct.
So just really take a
moment and take in oh,
how often am I going outside
when maybe I could go inside?
So here's what I get phone
calls for a lot, when
I come down to Silicon Valley
or I go into companies.
Hey, we need life work balance.
I think that's a great concept.
I think it's a great concept.
It's great to take a vacation.
But here's what happens, even
when people go on vacation,
they're still thinking.
They're still using
their smartphones.
They're-- it takes three
days to kind of wind down.
I lived in Hawaii.
People would come for a week.
I want go, uh-oh.
Because it took them
three, four days
just to feel their body again.
And then they'd be planning
on when they had to leave
and what they had
to get back to.
So work life balance is great.
But I'd like to go more
into mind body balance.
Meaning how often
I'm using my mind,
how often am I
unplugging and getting
into my body, exercise, yoga,
dance, movement, taking a walk,
swimming.
Here's the difference for me.
And this is so true.
When I wake up in
the morning and I
do my breathing exercises,
a little bit of stretching,
and then I go to the swimming
pool, I get all these ideas.
I get downloads in the water.
Like my whole day is, I've
set a tone for the day.
But when I don't do that and
I go right to the machines,
or right to the
phones, right to work.
It's a different day.
Because I'm already in my mind,
and my body's been left behind.
Does that make sense?
So we really need to activate
and stay in the body more
than anything.
So what I'd like to do is have
everybody take a few moments.
And for those of you that are
watching live, or watching this
later, you'll get
it on the screen.
We're going to ask you to just
take a moment with no judgment,
just to get an
assessment, just to have
an assessment of
basically where am I
in my body mind connection?
We're going to do this together.
One question at a time.
If you want to use a pen and
give yourself a score, you can.
At the end, you can
also go to a web link
and actually get a response
to your specific score,
as well as tips and videos and
audio that will support you.
No charge, just to
boost your score.
You'll have a 1 to 10.
For those of you
watching from out,
you'll be able to
go from 1 to 10.
One meaning not often.
10 meaning all the time.
So let's go through
this together.
The first question,
I consciously take
pauses from what I am doing
to take a few deep, full
relaxing breaths.
By the way, there was a
study-- The Framingham Study--
73% of our toxins are removed
from the respiratory system.
I never knew that.
I thought it was sweating,
going to the bathroom.
You probably did too.
That alone should make you
breathe more consciously.
73%, so we really need to clear
our toxins through the lungs.
OK.
Next question, I am generally
aware of my breathing dynamic.
For instance, I catch myself
when I'm holding my breath,
or notice when I'm breathing
labored or high up in my chest.
Just one if you never
do that, and 10 if you
always or somewhere
in the middle.
Third question is I scan my body
to connect with how I'm really
feeling in the moment.
For instance, I check to
see if my belly is relaxed,
my shoulders are
crunched, or to see if I'm
tightly gripping the phone.
Boy, I tell you what.
If you do spot checks
and scan your body
and keep that integrative
conversation going
between your brain and your
body, it's helped people.
I've gotten people that
had headaches and neck
aches because they
were crunched all day.
And they didn't know it.
Driving to work,
didn't know that they
were gripping the wheel.
Just that asking myself.
I have a lot of clients
just ask yourself
several times a day, what
am I noticing in my body
as I scan my body?
When I feel an uncomfortable
sensation, pain,
or emotion in my body, my
tendency is to tune into it
and listen to what it might
be telling me versus ignoring
my body or numbing myself.
A lot of us ignore our bodies.
We were told not to feel.
We were punished
if we felt. I even
have a story of recently when
I was in the hot springs,
a little girl was having
the best time in the pool.
Her mom came screaming up,
I've got some lemonade for you
honey.
And she looked up like, oh,
I'm having fun in the water.
But OK.
It wasn't a lemonade.
It was cucumber
water from the spa.
Now, I'm sorry.
Cucumber water is
not lemonade, right?
Lemonade's lemon, sugar, honey.
So this little
girl, I watched it,
this is what happens
to so many of us.
She drinks it.
She doesn't like it
and she hands it back.
But mom's disappointed.
Mom wants her to like it.
So mom says, it's good.
Try it again.
Well after about
three pleads from mom.
She finally goes,
Yeah, it's good.
And then mom walked away.
And the little girl contracted.
Just think about
that for a second.
Mommy, I'm hot in here.
It's not hot in here.
Oh.
What happens to the little
kid when they're told
they don't know what they feel.
AUDIENCE: They can't
trust their body.
They can't trust their emotions.
STEVE SISGOLD: You
can't trust your body.
You can't trust your--
so some of us heard that.
Even if it was benevolent like,
oh, this bathtub's too hot.
Oh, get in, it's fine.
I'm scared.
Oh, you're not scared.
Those kind of things
happen to many of us.
So many of us learn to
escape, to not feel it.
We don't want to feel it
because it's uncomfortable.
Or if we feel it and tell
somebody what we felt,
they might not believe us.
So the next question is, I'm
cautious of the negative things
I say about my body.
For instance, my boss
gives me a headache.
One client I work with
had a neck ache, back neck
ache for six years.
Take this in.
I said to him, what
started six years ago?
He said, let me think.
Let me-- oh, yeah,
I stopped paying--
I stopped paying the IRS.
I said, OK.
Let's see if there's a link.
What did you do when you
started not paying the IRS?
He said, Well, I got scared.
And I would always have this
saying, Oh, forget about it.
Put it in the back of my head.
Six years this guy had
off and on a headache.
I told him, Call the IRS.
They're not going to arrest you.
They're going to ask
for a monthly payment.
He called the IRS,
made a monthly payment,
headache went away.
What I'm trying to say is,
there's enough science,
if you look, that says, if you
say you know I hate my body.
My boss makes me sick.
That's a pain in my neck.
Your body's intelligent.
You're sending a thought.
You'll see a film soon that will
show you exactly what happens.
If you're sending that thought
every day, I'm not good enough.
I'm not going to get the job.
I'm-- whatever that is.
It starts to wire it in.
It gets fixed as an identity.
It gets fixed in the brain.
So that even though you want
to have another thought,
the brain is used to
and becomes addicted
to that emotional response.
Does that make sense?
The more we say it,
our body believes it,
and then we start to believe
that that's who we are.
And we're not.
We're not necessarily
any of those things
that people told us we were.
All right.
Just keep going
through the test.
I'm aware of how congruent my
words and body language are.
So when somebody says,
how are you doing?
You go, fine.
They're going to notice it.
You're gripping your jaw,
You're gripping your--
How often do you say something,
and your body language
is shaking?
When you say, no,
I'm good with it.
And then you're nervous.
Everybody picks up on that,
whether we know it or not.
More than ever,
people are very keen.
They're observant.
So if it's affecting how you
sell, how you communicate,
how you are in
your relationships,
just ask yourself, am I-- are
my words and my body congruent?
Are they aligned?
The next question for you
is, when I make decisions,
whether they're small or
large, do I listen to my body?
Take that in for a moment.
Do you make decisions
because somebody told you?
Do you make decisions because
you want to please somebody?
Do you make decisions just
off the top of your head?
Or do you take a
moment and go, boy,
when I was asked to do that,
why is my stomach tightening up?
Maybe there is something
to learn there.
Maybe your stomach has a memory.
Maybe your stomach--
your body reaction
is smarter than your
mind for the moment.
Maybe your body has something
that's very important.
So I've trained myself
to take a moment
and listen the loop of
awareness, back to the body,
to go, why is my body
having that response
to that belief, or that
abundance, or that love,
or that gift?
Why is my body
responding that way?
I'm aware of my posture.
This is really important.
When we get up and down,
when we sit at our desk,
when we get out of a car,
when we get in a car,
these are transitions that
the more aware you become
that's whole body intelligence.
I'm aware of how I get
up, how I sit down,
how I slouch, how I come home,
how I walk through the door.
Becoming more aware, it
doesn't mean you're a robot
and you're thinking
about it all the time.
It just becomes a new awareness.
Your brain starts to activate.
Oh, yeah, when she said
that I noticed I bent down.
Maybe I'll stand up.
I work with
presentations, speakers,
people who are on
stage, and they
have no idea that they're
up there shaking their hand.
Or they're talking
about one thing,
and their body's
giving another message.
It's just unconscious.
Once they become
aware of it, what
happens is they can make
that physical change, become
more congruent, and they'll
get a better result.
People will believe you more.
That's the key.
Because you'll be
more authentic.
I'm aware of any past
trauma, events, memories
that I hold in my body and how
they influence my behavior.
Real quicky, I'm
pretty confident.
Hopefully I look relaxed.
I love doing this.
This is what I do.
And I love doing it.
However, the first time
I left my neighborhood.
I grew up in a row house
neighborhood in Baltimore City.
You've seen films like Barry
Levinson, and other films.
That was my neighborhood.
And everything was safe.
Everybody was an aunt and uncle.
There were no locks,
never heard of crime,
never knew of anything other
than Hey, this is a good life.
23 cousins, we just
played ball in the street.
The first time about
three of my cousins and I
decided to leave the
neighborhood, the first time,
we went up to the
main thoroughfare.
I stuck out my thumb.
I was all excited to go.
And what happened was a car
pulled up with some rough guys
that I had never seen in my
life-- these kind of guys.
They got up.
They called us names.
They beat us up.
We ran home.
What's the belief?
Not here, because
I'm always excited.
But what's the belief that
sometimes my body might show me
before I get on a stage,
before I get on a big TV show,
before I get on something?
Does anybody want to
guess what the belief that
lives in my body is?
AUDIENCE: Fear.
STEVE SISGOLD: Fear of--
AUDIENCE: New things.
STEVE SISGOLD: New things.
It's big out there.
Hey, you're excited.
There's going to be a
million people watching this.
My mind's going, Woohoo!
All of a sudden my body goes,
oh my god, what's going on?
I've been in the green room
where I start to feel that.
And I realize, oh, rather
than trying to push that aside
and go do my interview.
What is that?
Oh, yeah, oh, that
reminds me of-- yeah.
OK.
So that happened then, my
body has a memory of it.
Things that happen
will trigger us.
And then we start
to make assumptions.
She's going to dump me.
My boss doesn't like my job.
I didn't do a good job.
But most of those are not true.
They're just old body memories.
And fortunately, I breathe.
I shake it out.
And I say the opposite.
I'm going to be safe.
People are going to love it.
I'm going to have a good time.
And my body relaxes.
And I go have a good interview.
So it's a really important thing
to remember is like, how aware
am I of how past
events affect me today?
Do I share what I
feel with people?
Or do I stuff it and hold it
in and let my body hold it?
That causes a lot of today's
modern illnesses and diseases,
stuff that's being held in.
Once you express it,
it makes a big change.
I set aside 30 minutes
a day, at least
30 minutes, to walk,
move, breathe, yoga,
something physical.
I have physical
techniques and practices
that I use to cope with.
And we're going to
practice one today called
the rebooting technique.
And then 13, I have a
stress management program
or ritual that I follow
daily, such as meditation,
prayer, somatic techniques.
So let me ask you
a question, anybody
that wants to call it out?
What did you learn?
Did you learn anything about
yourself, with no judgment,
from taking that
assessment test?
AUDIENCE: It was
kind of-- I think
I'm pretty good on
some of these things.
But like the one
about the when I
feel an uncomfortable sensation,
do I tune into it or ignore it?
But the thing is, I put
a little asterisk on it,
because I don't always, I'm
not always aware of them.
STEVE SISGOLD: Yeah, that's it.
We're not aware of it because
we're not in our body.
We're often in our
heads most of time.
Secondly just the idea of, when
I feel it, I have a choice.
Every moment's choice point.
Am I going to numb it?
Am I going to ignore it?
What I'm encouraging you to
do is feel it a little bit.
It's kind of like when you
put something in the laundry,
and you leave it in there.
It gets funky.
When you take it all the
way through the dryer, ah.
That's how I feel.
I taught my son that.
I teach everybody.
When you have a
feeling, get it out.
Move it through.
Don't have it build
up in your body.
OK.
So what I want to do,
the rebooting technique.
Then I'm going to show you
a little film on the brain.
And then I will take questions.
So this is a technique that
everybody can practice.
I'm working with 80
attorneys over at Ebay
who are doing this twice a day.
Communication's increased.
Everybody's feeling rebooted.
Bottom line is you're plugged
in so many hours a day.
I have an executive,
a sports executive,
really big organization.
He tells me, I have traumatic--
the worst part of my day
is 10 minutes.
Does anybody want to guess
what those 10 minutes are.
Just throw it out.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: When you put your
phone or your computer away.
STEVE SISGOLD: That's close.
Put my computer away.
The hardest part of his day
is the shower in the morning.
Isn't that crazy?
For 10 or 15 minutes,
he has mega anxiety
because separation
anxiety from the phone.
Who might be calling?
What did I miss?
Did a trade happen?
I know that sounds extreme.
But this is what I'm
seeing all the time.
The adrenaline of that phone.
Sending a text and until it
comes back with a response.
And then the brain, even
though we multitask a lot,
there's been so many studies.
I've got many in
my book, that show
that multitasking
actually-- we're
using one part of the
brain when we're speaking.
Another part of the
brain while we're typing.
Back and forth until our
brain gets exhausted.
And we press send and we're,
Oh, I didn't want to send that,
because we're not focused.
So our brain just
gets a lot of work
that we don't want
to have to deal with.
So let's go through
the rebooting.
Step one is to unplug.
And like I said in some
cases like that gentleman
it's really hard to unplug.
But I'm recommending
twice a day, just
like a meditation practice.
You go into the chill room
or you sit at your desk.
And you unplug, meaning
everything turns off.
Second, let's practice.
You take three deep
breaths from way
down here, through
your nose and just ah.
Relaxing the jaw.
A yawn is a stress release.
So feel how that feels.
You do three of those.
It's a simple technique.
Then you observe, like
we've been doing here today.
Just scan your body
and notice, ooh.
I didn't notice my
shoulder was up to my ear.
I didn't realize I
was leaning forward.
I was crunching my legs.
Four, you report to yourself.
The brain body is now
speaking to each other.
Oh, I'm noticing
my stomach's tight.
When she said that to me, I
noticed I got gripping my hand.
Step five, make an adjustment.
Shake it out.
Move it up.
Get up.
Shake out your body.
Just notice you can
move through that.
And then seven,
is reboot, meaning
take the time to actually notice
and make a conscious decision.
So before I walked in
here, before I met Van,
I sat in my car and I did
the rebooting technique
so I could be aligned.
Let the stress out, any stress
I was holding from driving down,
or anticipation of this talk.
And then I let it go.
And then I'm congruent.
I'm in my body.
And I'm in my mind.
This was a test done, just
to give you some validity,
at a medical center.
Lots of patients
went through it.
On an average, 55%
stress reduction
from doing these seven steps.
Heart went from
erratic to smooth.
That's what we want to do.
We want to have a smooth
relaxed day each day.
So these viral and vital
beliefs I told you about.
Now want to show you how
they affect our income.
So this is the brain.
And what you're seeing there
basically-- that's your brain.
That's so, the movie gave me
permission to use these clips.
So see those little sparks,
that's those thoughts.
If right now you're having
a thought like, Oh, god,
I got to go.
Or I'm feeling this.
What happened this morning.
I'm no good.
Whatever it is, that's
shooting a synapses,
that's shooting a
thought into your brain.
It's not just something
that's up here.
It's in here.
Now here's what happens.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The brain is made up of tiny
nerve cells called neurons.
These neurons have
tiny branches that
reach out and connect to other
neurons to form a neural net.
Each place where they
connect is integrated
into a thought or a memory.
Now the brain builds
up all its concepts
by the law of
associative memory.
For example, ideas,
thoughts, and feelings
are all constructed
and interconnected
in this neural net and all
have a possible relationship
with one another.
STEVE SISGOLD: Now here's the
key, watch what happens here.
-We know physiologically that
nerve cells that fire together,
wire together.
STEVE SISGOLD: This is
what happens in your brain
if you keep saying
something over and over.
- --of a long term relationship.
If you get angry
on a daily basis,
if you get frustrated
if you suffer on a daily
basis, if you give reasons
for the victimization
in your life,
you're rewiring
and reintegrating
that neural net
on a daily basis.
And that neural net now has
a long term relationship.
STEVE SISGOLD: You
don't ever know it
but you're thinking
that thought.
- --nerve cells
called an identity.
We also know that nerve cells
that don't fire together
no longer wire together.
They--
STEVE SISGOLD: This
is an intervention.
This is like rebooting, taking
a break from those thought.
Get up and move.
- -- that produces a chemical
response in the body.
Every time we interrupt
it, those nerve cells
that are connected to each other
start breaking the long term
relationship.
[END PLAYBACK]
STEVE SISGOLD: OK.
So just for a moment, to
yourself, think about one thing
that you would like to create
in your life right now.
Whether it's work,
whether it's a project,
whether it's bringing your art,
whether it's falling in love,
take a moment and just
think about something
that you want in your life.
Good.
What's happening in your
body as you think about it?
Sometimes people get tight.
Sometimes people get excited.
Just be aware.
Because what happens
is, when we have
those thoughts of our vision,
of our goals, or our dreams,
the body is responding.
Like the fellow who
couldn't embody success.
I worked with a person who
wrote hits, hit records.
And all of a sudden
he couldn't write.
And what happened was there were
memories that were coming up,
because it had been a
year since he toured.
And at the last tour, he
lost some people in his life,
had some negative things happen.
So in his body
was the memory of,
touring's not going
to be good for me.
And it blocked the brain.
So this is a lot of my work
has been helping people.
What could be blocking you
from just going all the way?
Like if I thought, Well, I can't
sell a book because everybody's
selling books.
And I'll never get a publisher.
And I don't have anything
important to say.
If I said that over
and over and over,
that would lock into a
neural net in my brain.
And I would never be
able to write a book.
So I intervene, shake that
out, say the opposite,
move the energy, and all of
a sudden, my brain's free.
And I'm starting
to open up a space
to actually be aware and
awake that I actually
could sell a book.
I actually could do well.
I could actually go up
four levels in my job.
I could actually create
somebody in my life
that's going to love me.
See, so the brain
is so important
but it comes through the body.
So what I want to ask before
we go into questions is,
ask yourself for a moment, what
did I learn about myself today?
Just take a mental
note, something
you learned about
yourself from this talk.
And secondly, what
will you do to-- OK.
What will you do to
get more resilient,
boosting your energy?
Just take a moment
and ask yourself that.
What did I take away from today?
And what can I do that would
make my life different?
Maybe it's breathing
more cautiously.
Maybe I learned
today that I want
to scan my body more and not
crunch up when I could be open.
Maybe I learned to communicate
instead of hold something in,
and catch those thoughts.
So is there any questions?
Anybody here have a question
that you would like to ask?
AUDIENCE: So where do
you find the balance
of maybe overcommunicating?
And how would you express that?
STEVE SISGOLD: Thank you.
Well, you know, I don't
go to the grocery store
and tell people, Hey,
I noticed today--
but I find it's really
important for me to number one,
communicate with myself
several times a day.
Oh, I'm gripping the wheel.
Glad I said I noticed that.
Also in my business
communications, my fiancee,
my son, my close, I'm
willing to say hey, when you
said that it didn't feel good.
I'm not making it about you.
But I'm inquiring.
What I really look for is
coworkers and collaborators
where we can go
in there together.
Hey, when you said that, it
brought up something for me.
And it's in my body.
Let me see what it is.
Tremendous new insights,
tremendous intimacy,
tremendous communication
comes out of that.
OK.
Thank you.
Does that help?
So the balance is if you're
feeling it strong enough,
you either have to
say it to yourself
and go outside and shake it out.
Or you need to communicate
directly to the person.
Because what'll happen
is, [BREATH IN] it
will implode inside of us.
And that's what causes a lot
of the disease in our bodies.
It's just overwhelmed.
Pamela Peeke, tremendous
person in stress,
she's at the
University of Maryland,
says, our bodies just can't
hold that many thoughts
and that much stress in a day.
So that's why I swim,
and breathe, and move,
and kind of balance it.
But I like to communicate
what I feel because that's
more what I'm engaging in
the moment, versus what
I'm projecting, assumptions,
blame, and so forth.
It's changed my life.
Just less stress on me,
better relationships.
AUDIENCE: Thanks again
for giving this talk.
It's been really great.
I had a question regarding
number four on the survey.
STEVE SISGOLD: Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked a little bit
about how when you have an
uncomfortable sensation,
it's better to
kind of internalize
it and realize what's going on
rather than just push it away.
Because even though you
try to-- I guess the goal
is kind of the same.
When you push it
away, you're trying
to overcome it with your mind.
But your body
still remembers it.
So I'm just wondering like
if you have any advice on how
do you go about helping your
body overcome it as well
and not just your mind?
STEVE SISGOLD: Thank you.
That's a great
question by the way.
So here's the thing,
when something comes up
that's uncomfortable, like
me being in the green room
and hearing my name and then
all of a sudden I get tense.
If I tried to push it
away, what would happen
is that would strain my
body, I would be faking it.
And I would go out
and do an interview
that was kind of like
still holding on to it.
So what I always do
is I breathe and I
feel where it is in my body.
And I go right to that spot.
And I touch it.
And I breathe into it.
And then maybe I shake.
And if I get in
touch with something,
I start to say the opposite.
You know, I am safe.
I will be fine.
I am going to be received.
Whatever it is.
But I think, in any case, if
you're feeling uncomfortable
about something, get some help.
Do some breathing.
Do some moving.
And go outside and move it.
Because what'll
happen is, the more
we swallow it, like
we saw in the film.
It just says, I can't feel.
Or I've got to hold on to this.
Quick story, somebody had
asthma in one of these talks.
I'm not a doctor.
But I just said, when
you breathe what happens?
It gets stuck.
And she was afraid to feel it.
It was uncomfortable.
Nobody wants to
feel uncomfortable.
But what happened is by feeling
it she got in touch with-- when
her grandfather died and she was
young, she was told don't cry.
Don't be upset.
Don't be angry at the funeral.
And she kept holding it.
And she got into a habit of
rather than saying what I feel,
I was trained to hold it in.
Asthma.
She expressed out what she
felt in a few sessions.
And the asthma went away.
In other words, get in
to get it off your chest.
That's literally it.
Get it off your chest.
MALE SPEAKER:
Thanks again, Steve.
STEVE SISGOLD:
Thank you so much.
Thank you everybody.
Thanks out there too.
[APPLAUSE]
Have an amazing day.